après un périple souvent périlleux pour
fuir leur pays
c'est un autre parcours du combattant
qui attend ces milliers de réfugiés ici
dès leur arrivée à montréal
ils seront prises en charge par le
moyenne scier le voyais m6 a aussi une
équipe d'employés à l'aéroport qui
s'occupe de les recevoir
les nouveaux arrivants à la sortie de
l'avion puis les transats les prendre en
charge éventuellement leur fournit des
vêtements d'hiver une autre saison de
besoin le royaume sied dispose de 150
chambres comme celle ci pour les loger
ils restent ici en moyenne combien de
temps dans une chambre comme ça alors ça
peut être entre deux le problème c'est
qu'en ce moment la majorité de ces
chambres sont déjà occupés le waï m6 a
donc demandé au ministère de
l'immigration du québec de pouvoir loger
les réfugiés dans l'hôpital pour enfants
situé à côté qui est fermé depuis son
transfert ou nouveau centre
universitaire de santé mcgill pendant ce
temps des coordonnateurs du centre
social des doses immigrants sont à la
recherche de logement dans l'île saint
laurent un quartier arabophone on
cherche des logements bon logement
effaceur sa vie revanche s de logements
où c'est la plupart des logements qu'on
cherche des quatre à dix mille cinq et
demi un logement que des réfugiés
devront payer avec l'aide sociale à
laquelle ils auront droit à part de
l'aide sociale bien sûr qu'ils sont
éligibles pour les allocations
familiales pour les enfants et tout le
reste c'est pas suffisant pour le loyer
mais il faut qu'ils se débrouillent
comme
tous les constituants canadien au centre
social des douze immigrants c'est le
branle bas de combat
l'organisme compte beaucoup sur la
communauté syrienne pour lui venir en
aide
la communauté syrienne pourrait nous
aider énormément et pour nous aider dans
le sens de faire du bénévolat pour leurs
propres compatriotes
et puis il faut songer aux enfants la
commission scolaire de montréal s'attend
à en recevoir entre 600 et 900 d'un coup
qu'est ce que ça prend des enseignants
halak est évidemment donc c'est des
enseignants qui sont spécialisés pour
l'intégration que la france va t'on des
élèves
donc ça va prendre un service d'accueil
avons les ressources pédagogiques les
ressources matérielles évidemment pour
avoir la des fournitures scolaires
l'ameublement pour aménager les classes
ça veut dire des dépenses
supplémentaires
une logistique de dernière minute qui
demande beaucoup d'efforts savons que ça
va être
compliqué étant donné les courts délais
pour les recevants il ne reste plus
maintenant qu'à établir un plan
d'accueil définitif en fonction
d'informations supplémentaires venant
d'ottawa ici catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal si tout se passe comme
prévu 2700 syriens seront bientôt
relocaliser dans la région de vancouver
la banque alimentaire de la ville de
syrie s'y préparent déjà ici dit elle on
est habitué à accueillir les immigrants
et les réfugiés de partout
mais qu'en est il des écoles qui dans
certains cas sont déjà assure capacités
dans la région
on est prêt à tout dit il mais il faudra
de l'aide logistique puis parmi les
associations musulmanes note en tout cas
pas attendu les détails du clan
d'accueil fédéral la collecte de fonds
dit moussa sy smile a déjà commencé
beaucoup de réfugiés seront probablement
d'abord abrité dans des bases militaires
comme celle de get down où l'on passe
déjà des commandes d'équipements au
magasin du coin entre autres des
machines à laver et des frigos dans cet
organisme d'accueil de réfugiés en
banlieue d'ottawa
on s'affaire à collecter de
l'ameublement pendant qu'à trois
rivières où on s'attend à accueillir
entre 150 et 200 réfugiés
la mobilisation se met en place on a
envoyé tout premier avis aux bénévoles y
recrutement des bénévoles et on a eu de
bonnes réponses parmi la population
ici à moncton près de 200 personnes se
sont déplacées ce soir pour en savoir
davantage sur les capacités d'accueil de
la région avec dieppe et riverview la
ville serait prête à recevoir environ
300 réfugiés les citoyens le voit d'un
bon oeil la région de moncton
assez dynamique je pense c'est
supportable pour la région et la bonne
volonté est aussi au rendez vous mais on
aimerait pouvoir aider d'une façon ou
d'une autre
partout au canada il semble donc
nombreux à attendre la date d'arrivée
des premiers avions frédéric donc on le
voit les canadiens les provinces les
villes se préparer cette s'organiser
mais en fait c'est ottawa qui vont
vraiment chapeauté cet accueil
oui c'est notamment bien sûr qu'il va
payer la note mais aussi qui s'occupe de
tout l'aspect logistique ont donc que ce
soit les transports trouver des
logements temporaires fournir également
les fameux chèque avec des montants qui
seront similaires à ceux de l'aide
sociale dans chacune des provinces
donc toute la répartition on va être
gérée par ottawa évidemment eu des
consultations avec les provinces et les
villes afin de vraiment d'identifier les
sites qui seront ciblés pour l'accueil
le québec c'est un peu différent puisque
vous le savez c'est la seule province
canadienne qui a son propre droit de
regard sur son immigration
donc là il ya treize villes qui ont
également été identifiés pour accueillir
ces réfugiés
il est impossible que douze villes
viennent se greffer là-dessus si elles
sont capables de démontrer qu'elles
seront aptes à faire cet accueil en fait
aux gens qui vont venir de la syrie